When Madison Nguyen was elected to the San Jose City Council, she was just 30 and was a really big deal. There is a huge Vietnamese community in San Jose, but no Vietnamese had ever made it to the city council.
当麦迪逊·阮（Madison Nguyen）当选圣何塞市议员时，她年仅30岁，这真是一件大事。圣何塞有着庞大的越南社区，但此前从未有越南人进入市议会。
The Vietnamese-American community was just beside themselves with having the very first Vietnamese-American elected official there.
越南裔美国社区对能有第一位越南裔民选官员感到欣喜若狂。
My Thuan Tran is the reporter who covers California's Vietnamese communities for the Los Angeles Times.
My Thuan Tran 是一位记者，专门为《洛杉矶时报》报道加州的越南社区。
They really saw her as the beloved daughter, as a golden child. There was a lot of celebrations. And she won and her face was all over different magazines. She was interviewed by all the Vietnamese press. People were following her every move. They wanted to know what she was up to.
他们确实把她视为心爱的女儿，视为金童。当时有很多庆祝活动。她赢了，她的脸出现在各种杂志上。她接受了所有越南媒体的采访。人们关注着她的一举一动。他们想知道她在做什么。
But within two years, mainly because of one issue. One issue. Lots of people were furious with Madison Nguyen.
但在两年内，主要是因为一个问题。就一个问题。许多人对麦迪逊·阮感到愤怒。
People started protesting in front of City Hall every single Tuesday. And they would hold banners that had a slash across her face. They wrote Madison Nguyen is a traitor. There was one protest that drew thousands of people, not only from San Jose but from the neighboring cities in the Bay Area, and also people who came from as far as Orange County or Houston.
人们开始每周二在市政厅前抗议。他们举着横幅，上面在她的脸上画了一个叉。他们写着“麦迪逊·阮是叛徒”。有一次抗议活动吸引了数千人，不仅来自圣何塞，还有来自湾区周边城市的人，甚至有人远从橙县或休斯顿赶来。
Also there was a hunger striker?
还有绝食抗议者吗？
Yes, there was. He was camped out in a tent for 29 days in front of City Hall and he was flanked by a lot of his supporters.
是的，有。他在市政厅前搭帐篷住了29天，身边有很多支持者。
And the main issue that turned so many people against Madison Nguyen? That eventually led to a special recall election for the golden child?
那么，导致那么多人反对麦迪逊·阮的主要问题是什么？是什么最终导致了对这位“金童”的特别罢免选举？
Well, there's a area of San Jose just a couple blocks long on Story Road, with lots of Vietnamese stores, and restaurants, and businesses. And one of the first things that Madison Nguyen did on the City Council was convince her colleagues they should do to economic development there, and designate that area with a special name.
嗯，圣何塞在 Story Road 上有一段几条街长的区域，那里有很多越南商店、餐馆和企业。麦迪逊·阮进入市议会后做的第一件事，就是说服她的同事们在那里进行经济开发，并给该地区起一个特别的名字。
Several possible names were discussed. Most Vietnamese Americans who cared enough to come out to those meetings preferred Little Saigon, but Madison Nguyen chose the name Saigon Business District. That's it. That's the whole controversy. Little Saigon versus Saigon Business District.
人们讨论了几个可能的名字。大多数愿意出来参加这些会议的越南裔美国人都倾向于“小西贡”（Little Saigon），但麦迪逊·阮选择了“西贡商业区”（Saigon Business District）。就是这样。这就是整个争议。小西贡还是西贡商业区。
I think the issue, it's a very subtle one. And I guess for a lot of non-Vietnamese, it was very difficult for them to understand, because they felt what's the difference? It's just Little Saigon versus Saigon Business District, but for many Vietnamese refugees, it just invoked everything that they had lived through in their lives. Of Vietnam and coming over here.
我认为这个问题非常微妙。我想对于很多非越南裔来说，很难理解，因为他们觉得有什么区别呢？不就是“小西贡”和“西贡商业区”的区别吗，但对于许多越南难民来说，这唤起了他们一生所经历的一切。关于越南，以及来到这里。
Specifically, the name Little Saigon had taken on huge significance. That's what some other Vietnamese exile communities like this big one that is down in Orange County had called themselves, partly as a political statement.
具体来说，“小西贡”这个名字具有巨大的意义。这正是像橙县那样的大型越南流亡社区对自己的称呼，部分是一种政治声明。
These communities, you got to remember, were full of people who had fought the Communists during the Vietnam War and then fled the Communists after the war. The name Little Saigon was seen as an act of defiance against people who had taken over the city of Saigon and renamed it. Renamed it, actually, after the founder of the Vietnamese Communist Party-- Ho Chi Minh City.
你要记住，这些社区里到处都是在越战期间与共产党战斗，战后又逃离共产党的人。名字“小西贡”被视为一种反抗行为，反对那些夺取西贡并将其更名——实际上是用越南共产党创始人的名字重新命名——为胡志明市的人。
The name that she did not choose, the name Little Saigon had just become such a symbol for them. It became a symbol for them of why they fled Vietnam, of why they fought for South Vietnam, of what hardships and pain that their family went through. And when she didn't choose that name, they felt like she wasn't listening to their stories, or to their history. Anything that wasn't Little Saigon, it's just seen as an insult.
她没有选择的名字，“小西贡”，对他们来说已经成为了一种象征。它成了他们为何逃离越南、为何为南越而战、他们的家庭经历了什么苦难和痛苦的象征。当她没有选择那个名字时，他们觉得她没有倾听他们的故事，或者说他们的历史。任何不是“小西贡”的名字，都被视为一种侮辱。
Me, on a personal level, I like the name Vietnam Town. Because we have Chinatown, we have Japantown, but obviously I guess what I liked didn't really matter.
就我个人而言，我喜欢“越南城”（Vietnam Town）这个名字。因为我们有唐人街，有日本城，但显然我想我喜欢的并不重要。
This is Councilwoman Madison Nguyen. The San Jose politician at the center of all this controversy. She says that although a vocal portion of her Vietnamese constituents definitely preferred Little Saigon, Vietnamese-Americans only make up a third of her district. Non-Vietnamese people and businesses in the district wanted other names. And she thought it would be better to avoid a name that was so political. So she chose what she thought was a compromise.
这位是市议员麦迪逊·阮。处于这场争议中心的圣何塞政治家。她说，尽管她选区中一部分声音响亮的越南裔选民确实更喜欢“小西贡”，但越南裔美国人只占她选区的三分之一。区内的非越南裔居民和企业想要其他名字。她认为避开一个如此政治化的名字会更好。所以她选择了她认为折中的方案。
And so I thought, OK, well both names have the name Saigon in it, and this is a business district designation. Why don't we just called it Saigon Business District and hopefully that will make everyone happy.
所以我当时想，好吧，两个名字都有“西贡”这个词，这是一个商业区指定。为什么我们不叫它“西贡商业区”，希望这样大家都会开心。
I want to play you a recording from this six and a half hour City Council meeting about this. And it's many people standing up, saying that they don't want this name. And here's one man and-- there's a point in the tape where he says if Madison wins, what he means is if you get your way and the community is not called Little Saigon. Here let me play this for you.
我想播放一段关于这场长达六个半小时的市议会会议的录音。很多人站起来说他们不想要这个名字。这里有一名男子，磁带里有一个点，他说如果麦迪逊赢了，他的意思是如果你得逞了，社区不叫“小西贡”。来，我放给你听。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频播放]
-Before 1975, I was Ranger Commander in Vietnam. I was in jail nine year. Tonight I come here to request only one vote from you for Little Saigon. I strongly support you from the beginning. But if Madison win, we stay away from her, because she's pro-Communist. Thank you.
-1975年之前，我是越南的游骑兵指挥官。我坐了九年牢。今晚我来这里，只请求你投“小西贡”一票。我从一开始就坚定支持你。但如果麦迪逊赢了，我们就远离她，因为她是亲共分子。谢谢。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频结束]
What's your reaction to that kind of thing?
你对那种事情有什么反应？
It was torture to have all these people, who are pretty much at the age of my parents or grandparents, coming up and looking you, staring you in the face, in your eyes and said we no longer trust you. You're not one of us. We regret that we ever supported you. To hear that over, and over, and over, and over again. I mean it's painful.
让所有这些年纪几乎和我父母或祖父母一样大的人，走过来盯着你的脸，盯着你的眼睛说我们不再信任你了。你不是我们的一员。我们后悔曾经支持过你，这简直是折磨。一遍又一遍地听到这些。我是说，这很痛苦。
Then there's the fact that she was being called a Communist, widely.
还有个事实是，她被广泛地称为共产党人。
The first time I heard it, I was very hurt. I felt that-- I came here as a boat child back in the late 1970s. I escaped Communism in Vietnam and I came here. We pretty much risked our lives to come to this great country. And to have this particular group of people in the Vietnamese community label me as a Communist sympathizer, I thought was really beyond absurd.
我第一次听到的时候，非常受伤。我觉得——我是在20世纪70年代末作为难民儿童来到这里的。我在越南逃离了共产主义并来到这里。我们几乎冒着生命危险来到这个伟大的国家。而越南社区中这一特定群体给我贴上“共产主义同情者”的标签，我认为简直荒谬至极。
Madison is convinced that if she had been a non-Vietnamese City Councilperson suggesting the exact same name, Saigon Business District, it never would have gone this far. No protest. Nobody would have been labeled a Communist.
麦迪逊确信，如果是一个非越南裔市议员提议完全相同的名字“西贡商业区”，绝不会闹到这一步。不会有抗议。没有人会被贴上共产党人的标签。
People felt betrayed, she says, because she was one of them. They expected her to do what they wanted. And they couldn't believe it when she didn't. To them, she was a turn coat. What strikes deeper than that?
她说，人们感到被背叛了，因为她是他们的一员。他们期望她做他们想要的事。当她没有那样做时，他们无法相信。对他们来说，她是变节者。还有什么比这更让人痛心的呢？
Well today on our show, we have two other stories of turncoats. It's This American Life from WBEZ in Chicago distributed by Public Radio International.
今天在我们的节目中，还有两个关于变节者的故事。这是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。
We'll get to those in a bit. In Madison Nguyen's case, things are ugly. Things happened pretty fast.
我们稍后会讲这些。在麦迪逊·阮的案例中，情况很糟糕。事情发生得很快。
If you listen to Vietnamese radio during that time period, a lot of people would come out and say they believe she was a Communist.
如果你在那个时期听越南语广播，很多人会出来说他们相信她是共产党。
Again, reporter My Thuan Tran.
再次是记者 My Thuan Tran。
I just felt that it was a really interesting case because it kind of showed the challenges of being a Vietnamese-American politician. That you kind of had to navigate among all these lingering emotions from this war that had ended 34 years ago.
我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的案例，因为它在某种程度上显示了作为一名越南裔美国政治家的挑战。你必须在战争结束34年后的所有这些挥之不去的复杂情感中穿行。
Yeah, you wrote, "The rules of politics are different for a Vietnamese-American politician. Even business owners, reporters, and pop singers carefully tiptoe around inferences and innuendo that can cast a person as being soft on Communism. A misstep can launch vocal protests and accusations. Reputations can be tarnished. People must bow to the pressure."
是的，你写道：“对于越南裔美国政治家来说，政治规则是不同的。即使是企业主、记者和流行歌手也会小心翼翼地避开那些可能把一个人打成‘对共产主义软弱’的推断和暗示。一步错就可能引发大声的抗议和指责。声誉可能受损。人们必须向压力低头。”
Right. I think it's a surprise for many people who are kind of unfamiliar with the Vietnamese-American community how much this name-calling and suspicion still resonates. I think some people feel like it looks like out of the McCarthy era when they view the Vietnamese-American community.
对。我认为对于许多不太了解越南裔美国社区的人来说，这种称呼和猜疑仍然如此盛行，令人惊讶。我认为当他们观察越南裔美国社区时，有些人觉得这就像麦卡锡时代。
There are tons of examples of this kind of red-baiting. The first Vietnamese Superintendent of Schools in the Westminster School District in Orange County was removed a week after she was appointed, she says, because an activist lobbied school board members, saying she was a Communist.
有大量的这种“红色诱饵”例子。橙县威斯敏斯特学区的第一位越南裔学区总监在她被任命一周后就被撤职了，她说，因为一位活动人士游说学校董事会成员，说她是共产党。
In Saint Paul, Minnesota, when a Catholic bishop visited from Vietnam, he asked that not be photograph with anything political. So his Vietnamese- American host in Minnesota, a man named Tuan Pham, took down the flag of the old country of South Vietnam which was in many exile communities. Tuan Pham was vilified as a pro-Communist because of that.
在明尼苏达州的圣保罗，当一位天主教主教从越南来访时，他要求不要拍摄任何政治内容。于是，他的越南裔美国东道主、一个叫 Tuan Pham 的人，取下了许多流亡社区中都会挂的旧南越国旗。Tuan Pham 因此被诋毁为亲共分子。
Protests at his store were so intense that customers stopped coming. His business went bankrupt. Tuan Pham not only battled the Communists as a soldier during the war, but was held in one of their prison camps for two years.
对他商店的抗议非常激烈，以至于顾客不再光顾。他的生意破产了。Tuan Pham 不仅在战争期间作为士兵与共产党作战，还在他们的监狱营中被关押了两年。
There's another interesting example I wanted to bring up. There was a Vietnamese-American pop singer named Tommy Ngo. And in one of the posters for a concert, he's wearing a belt with the word L-O-V-E on it. And the O has a star in it. And the word "LOVE" is in red and the star is white, but on the poster it kind of looked like the star was yellow. And a yellow star on a red background is actually the symbol of the official Vietnamese flag, which is known as the Communist flag. So, even that concert was protested against, and Tommy Ngo was protested against. And a lot of people didn't end up going to the concert.
我想提另一个有趣的例子。有一位名叫 Tommy Ngo 的越南裔美国流行歌手。在演唱会的海报上，他系着一条带“L-O-V-E”字母的腰带。字母“O”里有一颗星。单词“LOVE”是红色的，星星是白色的，但在海报上星星看起来有点像黄色的。红色背景上的黄色星星实际上是越南官方国旗的象征，也就是共产党的旗帜。所以，甚至那场演唱会也受到了抗议，Tommy Ngo 也受到了抗议。很多人最后没有去参加演唱会。
Even one of the contributors to our radio show, Thanh Tan, who is a reporter from Boise Public Television, has watched as her dad, who runs a Vietnamese community organization in Olympia, Washington, has been red-baited. It's particularly galling to her, she says, because she spent her childhood resenting how much time her dad spent at anti-Communist demonstrations.
甚至我们广播节目的贡献者之一、博伊西公共电视台的记者 Thanh Tan，也看着她经营华盛顿州奥林匹亚一家越南社区组织的父亲受到“红色诱饵”攻击。她说这让她特别气愤，因为她童年的大部分时间都在怨恨父亲花在反共示威上的时间。
It's just really upsetting to hear these accusations against somebody who-- his idea of fun with the family was to take us to a protest in Seattle, and to wave around the old nationalist flag, the yellow flag with the three stripes.
听到这些针对某个人的指控真是让人心烦——他认为和家人在一起的乐趣就是带我们去西雅图抗议，挥舞那面旧的民族主义旗帜，也就是带有三条杠的黄旗。
You mean an anti-Communist protest?
你是说反共抗议？
Yeah. Like, I grew up on that. I have pictures of me when I was like, six years old, holding a sign that says Ho Chi Minh is a criminal.
是的。就像，我是在那种环境下长大的。我有我大约六岁时举着写有“胡志明是罪犯”标语的牌子的照片。
Thanh's dad has now won a defamation against the activists who called him a Communist sympathizer. The Thurston County Court awarded him and his organization $310,000. But Thanh says that the stress of all this has hurt her parents' marriage and her dad's health. And somehow her family doesn't feel a sense of victory after all this.
Thanh 的父亲现在已经赢得了针对称他为共产主义同情者的活动人士的诽谤官司。瑟斯顿县法院判给司他和他的组织31万美元。但 Thanh 说，这一切带来的压力伤害了她父母的婚姻和父亲的健康。而且不知何故，她的家庭在这一切之后并没有感受到胜利的感觉。
You know, I don't just because like right after the trial, like within a week, I saw a television, like a Vietnamese television report where the defendants were interviewed. And the main guy, he said that my dad-- he said something along the lines of Communists don't wear their badge on their chest. And to me that just said going through this whole trial, three week trial was not enough to prove to him that my dad apparently is not a Communist. And that really was pretty upsetting.
你知道，我没有，因为就在审判后，大概一周内，我在电视上看到了一篇越南语电视报道，采访了被告。主要的那个人说，我父亲——他说了一些类似于“共产党人不会把徽章戴在胸前”的话。对我来说，这只是说明经历这次审判，三周的审判，不足以向他证明我父亲显然不是共产党人。这真的相当令人心烦。
I mean my mother, she calls me, and she just said Thanh, what do we do? Like, what we do? Like, the Vietnamese media is still reporting that your dad could be a Communist. Like, I don't know what to do.
我是说我母亲，她打电话给我，只是说：“Thanh，我们该怎么办？像，我们该怎么办？越南媒体还在报道你父亲可能是共产党。我不不知道该怎么办。”
I understand that there's a Vietnamese phrase for red-baiting that's used here in the States.
我明白，这里在美国使用的一个越南词汇是用来形容“红色诱饵”的。
Mm-hmm. It's called "chup mu."
嗯。它被称为“chup mu”。
And what does it mean literally?
那字面意思是什么？
It literally means to put the Communist hat on someone.
字面意思是给某人戴上共产党的帽子。
The City Councilwoman in San Jose, Madison Nguyen, faced a recall election and she won. Mainly, she's just tired of the red-baiting. At the height of all the protests she wondered, is this why we came to this country? So we could fight over who's a Communist?
圣何塞的市议员麦迪逊·阮面临罢免选举，但她赢了。主要是因为她对“红色诱饵”感到厌倦。在所有抗议活动达到顶峰时，她想，这就是我们来到这个国家的原因吗？这样我们就可以为了谁是共产党而吵架？
Even now, which is really sad, but I'll share with you anyways. My in-laws, they're still living in Vietnam right now, and I was recently married. And my father-in-law had a stroke about two months ago. And so, I wanted to have the opportunity to go back. But I can't, because I know that if I go back now, imagine what's going to happen when I come back here to San Jose.
即使是现在，这真的很难过，但我还是会跟你分享。我的姻亲现在还住在越南，我最近结婚了。我的公公大约两个月前中风了。所以，我想有机会回去看看。但我不能，因为我知道如果我现在回去，想象一下当我回到圣何塞时会发生什么。
You can't say you're visiting a relative?
你不能说你是去探亲吗？
Yeah, good luck.
是的，祝你好运。
Why? What will they say?
为什么？他们会说什么？
I mean, I really-- and when I tell people, I tell my friends that, they're like, there's no way you can go because if you go, the first thing that's going to happen when you come back is that, oh look! She's going back there. She's probably trying to connect with the Vietnamese government, or get in some kind of relationship.
我是说，我真的——当我告诉别人，我告诉我的朋友时，他们说，你绝不可能去，因为如果你去了，当你回来时发生的第一件事就是，哦看！她回去了。她可能试图与越南政府建立联系，或者建立某种关系。
And so it's just-- and so, here I am thinking like, am I ready to put up another fight?
所以它只是——所以我在这里想，我准备好再打一场仗了吗？
She says she doesn't want to put her supporters through all that again. So she's careful. But she wants to be in politics, she says. With so many people ready to see her as a traitor. And that's just how it's got to be.
她说她不想再让她的支持者经历这一切。所以她很谨慎。但她说她想从政。尽管有那么多人准备把她视为叛徒。而事情只能如此。
Act Two, My Way or the FBI Way.
第二幕，我的方式还是 FBI 的方式。
On the morning of September 3, 2008, the day Sarah Palin would address the Republican National Convention, a SWAT team broke down the door of a home in downtown Saint Paul. Local TV news had this story.
2008年9月3日早上，也就是莎拉·佩林（Sarah Palin）将在共和党全国代表大会上发表演讲的那天，一支特警队破门进入了圣保罗市中心的一所房子。当地电视新闻报道了这个故事。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频播放]
-Two Texas man are now charged with plotting to attack police with molotov cocktails during the Republican National Convention.
-两名德克萨斯州男子目前被控在共和党全国代表大会期间密谋用燃烧瓶袭击警察。
-Police say David McKay and Bradley Crowder are both associated with the radical Austin Affinity Group. If convicted, McKay and Crowder could face up to 10 years in prison.
-警方称，大卫·麦凯（David McKay）和布拉德利·克劳德（Bradley Crowder）都与激进的奥斯汀亲和小组有关联。如果罪名成立，麦凯和克劳德可能面临长达10年的监禁。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频结束]
Two men who'd been arrested were young, in their early 20s. The RNC was their first big protest. And they'd been nabbed in an elaborate sting operation. Word spread around the country among activists that there was an informant in their midst. And it had to be somebody big. But who? And why? The rumors started circulating about one guy. A guy who'd been notorious even before this. Michael May tells what happened.
被捕的两名男子很年轻，二十出头。这次共和党全代会是他们的第一次大型抗议活动。他们是在一次精心设计的诱捕行动中被抓获的。活动人士中传言，他们中间有线人。而且肯定是个大人物。但是是谁？为什么？关于一个人的流言开始传播。一个即使在此之前就已经声名狼藉的人。迈克尔·梅（Michael May）讲述了发生了什么。
Four months after the Republican National Convention, Brandon Darby posted a letter on Indymedia, a website used by activists worldwide from Chiapas to London to Seattle. "To all concerned," he wrote.
共和党全国代表大会四个月后，布兰登·达比（Brandon Darby）在 Indymedia 上发布了一封信，这是一个全世界从恰帕斯到伦敦再到西雅图的活动人士使用的网站。“致所有相关人员，”他写道。
There are currently allegations in the media that I have worked undercover for the Federal Bureau of Investigation.
目前媒体中有指控称我为联邦调查局（FBI）做卧底。
The allegations seemed ludicrous. Everybody knew Brandon Darby hated cops. He talked openly about overthrowing the US government.
这些指控看起来很荒谬。每个人都知道布兰登·达比讨厌警察。他公开谈论推翻美国政府。
One of his friends, a sort of living legend among anarchists, had posted his own earlier letter on Indymedia saying, "The idea of Brandon working for the FBI was absurd. It would be the biggest lie of my life since I found out the truth about Santa Claus as a child."
他的一个朋友，在无政府主义者中算是一个活着的传奇，在 Indymedia 上发布了他自己更早的信，说：“布兰登为 FBI 工作的想法是荒谬的。这会是我自童年发现圣诞老人的真相以来，我一生中最大的谎言。”
You can see where this is going.
你可以看出事情会走向何方。
The simple truth is that I have chosen to work with the Federal Bureau of Investigation. Many of you went against my wishes and spoke publicly in defense of me. I really did mean it when I said I didn't want to discuss it, and that I didn't want folks addressing the allegations. I'm looking forward to open dialogue and debate regarding the motivations and experiences I've had, and the ethical questions they pose.
简单的事实是，我选择了与联邦调查局合作。你们许多人违背了我的意愿，公开为我辩护。当我说我不想讨论它，也不想让大家处理这些指控时，我是认真的。我期待着就我所拥有的动机和经历，以及它们提出的伦理问题进行公开的对话和辩论。
What followed wasn't debate and dialogue. It was vitriol. People were shocked. Brandon Darby was one of the best-known radical activists in the South.
随后的并不是辩论和对话。而是尖刻的谩骂。人们感到震惊。布兰登·达比是南方最著名的激进活动家之一。
In Austin, Texas, where he lives, posters with Brandon's face went up on bulletin boards, at coffee shops, and stores around town. The poster said, "BEWARE! BRANDON DARBY, FBI INFORMANT RAT LOOSE IN AUSTIN!" Brandon still has some loyalists in activist community, but for the most part he's hated. I've interviewed probably 20 people who know or worked with Brandon, and their feelings about him now are pretty extreme.
在他居住的德克萨斯州奥斯汀市，布兰登的脸出现在布告栏、咖啡店和城里的商店里。海报上写着：“当心！布兰登·达比，FBI 线人，奥斯汀出没的耗子！”布兰登在活动界仍有一些忠诚者，但在大多数情况下他被憎恨。我采访过大约20个认识或与布兰登合作过的人，他们现在对他的感觉非常极端。
I first met Brandon two weeks after Hurricane Katrina. I did a story about him for our local radio station in Austin. And Brandon had this crazy, true story to tell. He bought a boat and drove from Austin to New Orleans after the storm to find his friend, a former Black Panther named Robert King Wilkerson, who lived in a flooded neighborhood.
我第一次见到布兰登是在卡特里娜飓风发生两周后。我为我们在奥斯汀的当地电台报道过他的故事。布兰登有一个疯狂的、真实的故事要讲。暴风雨后，他买了一艘船，从奥斯汀开车到新奥尔良，去寻找他的朋友，一位住在被洪水淹没的社区的前黑豹党成员罗伯特·金·威尔克森（Robert King Wilkerson）。
Brandon couldn't get the boat into the city, so he decided to wade in. At the time, he told the story like that was the only reasonable thing to do.
布兰登没能把船开进城里，于是决定涉水进去。当时，他讲这个故事就像那是唯一合理的做法一样。
I came under an overpass and there are law enforcement officers on the overpass. And they stopped me and they told me to wait there. That I didn't have a reason to be there or right to be there and asked me who I was. And I told them I was going to get my friend. And they said you can't do that. And I said, well, I don't mean to be rude, but you're on an overpass and I'm down here. And so I really don't see how you're going to stop me from getting my friend.
我来到一座立交桥下，桥上有执法人员。他们拦住了我，让我等在那里。说我没有理由或权利呆在那里，并问我是谁。我告诉他们我要去接我的朋友。他们说你不能这么做。我说，好吧，我不是想粗鲁，但你们在立交桥上，而我在下面。所以我真的不明白你们怎么能阻止我接我的朋友。
So Brandon literally swam into the fetid water. And when he couldn't reach his friend's house on his own, he somehow, while stranded on a fence pole, badgered the Coast Guard into rescuing Wilkerson.
所以布兰登真的游进了恶臭的水中。当他无法独自到达他朋友家时，他不知怎么地，在被困在一根篱笆柱上时，纠缠海岸警卫队救出了威尔克森。
The story became famous among activists in New Orleans. And it sums up Brandon pretty well-- a mixture of heroism, recklessness, and arrogance.
这个故事在新奥尔良的活动人士中变得很有名。它很好地总结了布兰登——英雄主义、鲁莽和傲慢的混合体。
Brandon Darby looks a little like an action hero. Six-foot-plus, stubble, he's got some muscle. Good looking in a rugged movie star sort of way, down to the cleft chin. And he didn't become a political activist after taking a Marxist theory class. He didn't go to college. He was a smart guy from a crappy Gulf Coast refinery town who spent a lot of his teenage years running away from home. He lived on the streets of Houston, and was in and out of group homes and treatment centers.
布兰登·达比看起来有点像动作英雄。六英尺多高，胡茬，肌肉发达。长得很有硬汉电影明星的架势，连下巴都有裂纹。他并不是在上了马克思理论课后才成为政治活动家的。他没上过大学。他是来自墨西哥湾沿岸一个破败炼油厂城镇的聪明人，青少年时期大部分时间都在离家出走。他住在休斯顿街头，进出过收容所和治疗中心。
By the time he hit 20 with an eighth grade education and GED, he learned what he took as the central lesson of his life. People in power lie and take advantage of people weaker than themselves. And when he moved to Austin, he discovered radical politics. He showed up at the Anarchist Bookstore, read up, and started channeling his anger towards the US government. And it all came to a head after Hurricane Katrina.
当他20岁，只有八年级教育程度并拿到同等学历证书时，他学会了他一生中最核心的一课。掌权者撒谎，占弱者的便宜。当他搬到奥斯汀时，他发现了激进政治。他出现在无政府主义书店，博览群书，开始将他的愤怒引向美国政府。这一切在卡特里娜飓风后达到了顶峰。
I believed for years that the government was out of control and that it didn't have any concern for the average person. And then Katrina happened, and it reinforced it 500%. I was very dedicated and sure that it would be a huge error on my part to spend any time trying to work with or change our government. And that they just were so rotten to the core, I needed to do something about it. And that maybe I needed to become a revolutionary who believed in overthrowing the state.
多年来我一直相信政府已经失控，它对普通人没有任何关心。然后卡特里娜发生了，它强化了这一点500%。我非常投入，并且确信如果我花任何时间试图与我们的政府合作或改变它，那将是我巨大的错误。他们烂到了骨子里，我需要做点什么。也许我需要成为一个相信推翻国家的革命者。
So he moved to New Orleans. And post-Katrina New Orleans was the perfect place for someone who believed sincerely and literally in the overthrow of the US government. A wasteland with no functioning central authority is a paradise for anarchists.
所以他搬到了新奥尔良。卡特里娜飓风后的新奥尔良对于那些真诚地、字面上相信推翻美国政府的人来说是完美的地方。一个没有功能性中央权威的荒原是无政府主义者的天堂。
It was a chance to prove what Brandon and others already believed. Government sucks. We can create a better world without it. So he and three other more experienced activists started up a relief organization with $50.00 and named it Common Ground.
这是一个证明布兰登和其他人已经相信的东西的机会。政府烂透了。我们可以在没有它的情况下创造一个更美好的世界。所以他和另外三名经验丰富的活动人士用50美元建立了一个救援组织，并将其命名为“共同基础”（Common Ground）。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频播放]
-In the vast plain of devastation that is the lower ninth ward of New Orleans, there's a little blue house. It shines in the sun like a wild flower amid the wreckage. And it was here, at the little blue house on Desland Street that we found something rare in New Orleans. A real success story. An American success story. It's called Common Ground.
-在新奥尔良下九区这片广阔的荒原上，有一座蓝色的小房子。它在废墟中像野花一样在阳光下闪耀。就在这里，在德斯兰街（Desland Street）的蓝色小房子里，我们发现了一些在新奥尔良很稀有的东西。一个真正的成功故事。一个美国成功故事。它叫“共同基础”。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频结束]
That's from Nightline. Common Ground might have been heralded as an American success story and a wild flower by the time the mainstream media found them a year later. But at the beginning, it was a bunch of outraged radicals. Anarchists promising to deliver relief by any means necessary.
那是《夜线》（Nightline）节目的报道。“共同基础”在主流媒体一年后发现他们时，可能已经被誉为美国的成功故事和野花。但在最初，它是一群愤怒的激进分子。无政府主义者承诺不计一切代价提供救援。
They were the only relief group here in the upper Ninth Ward.
他们是上九区唯一的救援小组。
Ken Gaspard grew up in the Ninth Ward.
肯·加斯帕德（Ken Gaspard）在九区长大。
Red Cross was handing out food in uptown New Orleans where no damage was happening. You couldn't find Red Cross down here in the Ninth Ward. To this day, I will not give Red Cross a dollar of my money for that reason.
红十字会在没有受灾的上城区发放食物。你在九区根本找不到红十字会。直到今天，我绝对不会给红十字会一美元，就是因为这个原因。
Within weeks after Katrina, Common Ground, with Brandon leading the Ninth Ward effort, became a force. Providing meals, health care, and help with gutting houses, all for free. They didn't have permits or anything. They just did it, and police did not like it. Common Ground was being run out of the house of a former Black Panther name Malik Rahim. And Brandon says it quickly became a target.
卡特里娜飓风后的几周内，在布兰登领导九区工作的情况下，“共同基础”成了一股力量。提供免费的饭菜、医疗和帮助清理房屋，全部免费。他们没有任何许可证之类的东西。他们只是做了，而警察不喜欢这样。“共同基础”是在前黑豹党成员马利克·拉希姆（Malik Rahim）的房子里运作的。布兰登说它很快就成了目标。
The police would show up every night at Common Ground at Mailk's house and they would find some means of intimidating the hell out of us.
警察每晚都会出现在“共同基础”马利克的房子里，他们会想方设法恐吓我们。
Specifically what would they say?
具体他们会说什么？
Arrest everybody for things. Like, I almost got arrested because I didn't have proof that my car was registered. And I was like, well look at my sticker. And they go, yeah, but do you have a receipt for it? And I was like, I don't think I need a receipt. They're like, well Mr. Darby if you don't have a receipt, I'm going to arrest you. And it's like, well, OK, I guess you're going to arrest me, because I don't this-- like really find infractions to arrest us with.
以各种事情逮捕每个人。比如，我差点被捕，因为我没有我的车已注册的证明。我说，看看我的贴纸。他们说，是的，但你有收据吗？我说，我想我不需要收据。他们说，嗯，达比先生，如果你没有收据，我就逮捕你。这就像，好吧，我想你会逮捕我，因为我没有这个——就像真的寻找违规行为来逮捕我们一样。
We did have a hard early going.
我们的起步确实很难。
Major John Bryson with the New Orleans Police Department was in command of the Ninth Ward.
新奥尔良警察局的约翰·布赖森（John Bryson）少校负责九区。
One of the first people that I ran into on the streets was Brandon Darby. I invited Darby and his staff over to the Fifth District police station where we met in a trailer, of all things. That's what we were actually working out of, temporary trailers. And it was a very interesting first meeting. Brandon kept interrupting what I was telling him, what was expected of them. And he laid some expectations down on police.
我在街上遇到的第一个人就是布兰登·达比。我邀请达比和他的员工到第五区警察局，我们在那里的一辆拖车里开了会。那就是我们实际工作的地方，临时拖车。那是非常有趣的第一次会议。布兰登不断打断我告诉他的内容，我对他们的期望。他给警察设定了一些期望。
He kept saying that you don't understand, I'm an activist. I said yes, Mr. Darby, I know you're an activist, and I'm just being just as polite as I could be. But Brandon was at my throat. He kept saying that you don't understand, we're going to be videotaping you, we're going to be audiotaping you. I mean he was-- very aggressive meeting, I would say, on his part.
他不停地说你根本不明白，我是活动家。我说是的，达比先生，我知道你是活动家，我已经尽可能礼貌了。但布兰登在我的喉咙口。他不停地说你根本不明白，我们要录像，我们要录音。我是说他——非常激进的会议，我可以这么说。
But over the coming days and weeks and months of watching them do what they did. Bringing in, my God, doctors and feeding people. It was just a work of art. And I'm not saying this is what they said. I'm telling you what I saw. And we were scratching our heads trying to figure out, well, where's the government?
但在接下来的几天、几周和几个月里，看着他们做所做的事情。带进——天哪，医生，给人们喂食。这简直是一件艺术品。我并不是说这是他们说的。我是告诉你我看到的。我们当时抓耳挠腮想弄明白，那么政府在哪里？
At the same time Bryson was changing his mind about Common Ground, Brandon began changing his mind about Bryson. It started when he got a call from Bryson.
与此同时，布赖森在改变对“共同基础”的看法，布兰登也开始改变对布赖森的看法。这是从他接到布赖森的一个电话开始的。
He said, hey Brandon. I was driving around my district, thinking of how much I dislike you and what you stand for. And I was like, I was just thinking about how much I dislike you, too. And he was like, but I came across all these youngsters who said that you had given them medicine to deliver to elderly residents. A lot of them I know.
他说，嘿布兰登。我在我的辖区开车，想着我是多么讨厌你和你代表的东西。我说我当时也正在想我是多么讨厌你。他说，但我遇到了所有这些年轻人，他们说你给了他们药品送到老年居民那里。他们中的很多人我认识。
And I said yeah, that's what we do. And he goes, well I'm having a hard time disliking you when you're doing stuff like that. And I said well, I'm having a hard time disliking you when you're talking to me like this. And that was the start of an interesting friendship.
我说是的，这就是我们做的。他说，嗯，当你做这种事情的时候，我很难讨厌你。我说嗯，当你这样跟我说话时，我也很难讨厌你。那就是一段有趣友谊的开始。
Brandon, to his surprise, started thinking that maybe he and some of the police in New Orleans were actually on the same side, trying to do the same thing. Fix a crippled city. Meanwhile, Brandon found himself in an organization with hundreds of volunteers and no clear hierarchy. Others at Common Ground wanted to run the organization by consensus, where everyone gets a say and no one walks around telling other people what to do. But Brandon came to believe that the volunteers did need someone telling them what to do. And what not to do.
布兰登令他惊讶的是，开始认为也许他和新奥尔良的一些警察实际上是在同一战线上，试图做同样的事情。修复一个残废的城市。与此同时，布兰登发现自己处于一个有数百名志愿者且没有明确层级的组织中。其他人想要通过共识来管理“共同基础”，即每个人都有发言权，没有人走来走去告诉别人做什么。但布兰登开始相信，志愿者确实需要有人告诉他们做什么。以及什么不该做。
Folks would take over the kitchen and decide because they were the kitchen now, and they wouldn't tell you this before they took over the kitchen responsibilities, but then once they took over the kitchen responsibilities, it became a vegan kitchen.
人们会接管厨房，决定因为他们现在是厨房，他们不会在接管厨房责任之前告诉你，但一旦接管了厨房责任，它就成了纯素食厨房。
That's like, well, A, we're relying on handouts here. Like we don't have money to buy food ourselves to feed people. And, B, the people we're serving don't want vegan food. They might not like ginger noodles every day. And like, well our kitchen has decided-- that we as the kitchen crew have decided through our process that we're not going to serve oppression. And I was like, well, then I've decided that you're not going to work in the kitchen.
这就像，嗯，A，我们在这里依赖捐赠。我们没有钱自己买食物来喂饱人们。而且，B，我们服务的人不想吃纯素食。他们可能不想每天都吃姜丝面。我想，嗯，我们的厨房决定——作为厨房团队，我们通过流程决定我们不会提供压迫。我说，那么我已经决定你不会在厨房工作了。
A lot of people were mad because, well I don't consense on working in a church because churches are patriarchal, and churches are-- And I say, well, then don't work in a church, but we're working in the church. Thankfully there's like 20 other areas of the city that are open for leadership. Why don't you go talk to Malik and ask Malik if you can take that area and run that area how you see fit.
很多人很生气，因为，嗯，我不同意在教堂工作，因为教堂是父权制的，教堂是……我说，好吧，那别在教堂工作，但我们就在教堂里。幸好城市里还有20个其他区域对领导力开放。为什么不去跟马利克谈谈，问问马利克你能不能接管那个区域，按你认为合适的方式运营那个区域。
Brandon had rebelled against authority his entire life. He didn't trust authority figures. Now he was the authority figure. And this was one of many ways that Brandon was finding himself out of sync with the anarchists at Common Ground. Brandon yelled at people. He ate meat. He slept with a lot of women. Plenty of them Common Ground volunteers. He owned guns. A lot of people thought he was a bully, including the other people who created Common Ground-- Scott Crowe, Malik Rahim, and Lisa Fithian.
布兰登一生都在反抗权威。他不信任权威人物。现在他是权威人物。这也是布兰登发现自己与“共同基础”的无政府主义者格格不入的多种方式之一。布兰登对人大喊大叫。他吃肉。他和很多女人睡觉。她们中很多人是“共同基础”的志愿者。他有枪。很多人认为他是个欺凌者，包括其他创造“共同基础”的人——斯科特·克劳（Scott Crowe）、马利克·拉希姆和丽莎·菲西安（Lisa Fithian）。
He didn't ask a lot of times. He just assumed that nobody knew what they were doing. And he was going to do it, even though he'd never organized anything, never organized, never organized anything. Zero.
他很多时候不问。他只是假设没有人知道他们在做什么。他要去做，尽管他从未组织过任何事情，从未组织，从未组织任何事情。零。
You know, Common Ground wouldn't be, I know we wouldn't be around now if Brandon would still be here because of the chaos that he started and he perpetuated.
你知道，“共同基础”不会存在，我知道如果布兰登还在这里，我们不会存在，因为他引发并延续的混乱。
It was all about him if Brandon's all about the community, he's all about community if he gets to be the savior.
如果布兰登是关于社区的，那么如果他能成为救世主，他才全是关于社区的。
A documentary on YouTube shows Brandon at his desk when he was in charge of Common Ground. He sits in front of a boarded-up window with a sign on it that says "Stop police corruption. Call Brandon Darby." In the video, he launches into one of his signature political rants that manages to connect Katrina to just about any other historical injustice he can think of.
YouTube 上的一部纪录片展示了布兰登在负责“共同基础”时坐在办公桌前的样子。他坐在一个用木板封住的窗户前，上面有一个写着“停止警察腐败。致电布兰登·达比”的牌子。在视频中，他开始了标志性的政治咆哮之一，设法将卡特里娜飓风与他能想到的任何其他历史不公正联系起来。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频播放]
-Yes, the same people that decided, you know, inject black men with syphilis in Tuskegee and, and decided to drop an atomic bomb that caused cancer in millions and millions of people. We have these people deciding when it is or is not appropriate to deliver humanitarian aid.
-是的，正是那些决定——你知道，在塔斯基吉给黑人注射梅毒，并决定投下原子弹导致数百万人患癌症的人。我们有这些人决定什么时候合适以及什么时候不合适提供人道主义援助。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频结束]
But the more Brandon talked to the residents in New Orleans, the people he was trying to help and trying to sell them on his politics, the less he could avoid yet another unsettling conclusion.
但布兰登与新奥尔良的居民交谈得越多，他试图帮助的人以及试图向他们兜售他的政治观点的人越多，他就越无法避免另一个令人不安的结论。
As much as I might want revolution, the residents don't.
尽管我可能想要革命，但居民们不想要。
For instance, Brandon had a plan that he was excited about. When the president of Venezuela, Hugo Chavez, made a grandstanding offer to help New Orleans after Katrina, Brandon wanted to take him up on it.
例如，布兰登有一个让他很兴奋的计划。当委内瑞拉总统雨果·查韦斯（Hugo Chavez）在卡特里娜飓风后提出帮助新奥尔良的做秀提议时，布兰登想接受它。
Initially, a lot of residents were cool. They're like, I don't care who helps us. But after a while a lot of them weren't. And it was like, yeah, but we can get money and they can build trailers for you, like Chavez trailers. If the FEMA is not going to give you trailers like they're supposed to by law, we'll get Chavez trailers. And then the US government will look at that and go, gee, this is embarrassing. We better build FEMA trailers for them.
起初，很多居民觉得很酷。他们说，我不在乎谁帮助我们。但过了一段时间很多人就不这么看了。就像，是啊，但我们可以得到钱，他们可以为你建造拖车，比如查韦斯拖车。如果联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）不按法律规定给你拖车，我们就弄查韦斯拖车。然后美国政府会看着那个说，天哪，这太尴尬了。我们最好给他们建 FEMA 拖车。
And there were like, no, bro. I love my country. It ain't about that for me. My kid's in the military, man. I support my kid in the military. I just want my house, and I want my kids to come back, and I want my grandma's house next door to get fixed. That's all I want. I don't want the Ayatollah buying me any houses. That's OK. I'd rather be homeless.
他们就像，不，兄弟。我爱我的国家。对我来说不是那样的。我的孩子在军队里，伙计。我支持我在军队里的孩子。我只想拿回我的房子，我想要我的孩子们回来，我想要我奶奶隔壁的房子被修好。这就是我想要的。我不想要阿亚图拉给我买任何房子。没关系。我宁愿无家可归。
See, these people in the Ninth Ward ain't activists, bro. They ain't going to be activists.
看，九区的这些人不是活动家，兄弟。他们不会成为活动家。
Ken Gaspard again. The Ninth Ward resident.
肯·加斯帕德再次出现。九区居民。
You know, at one point, they wanted me to come with them to protest the closing, tearing down of one of the low-income projects. I asked him are you [BLEEP] crazy? 'Cause you know what? They'll look at you and go like, hmm, he ain't from here. But me? I'll be the first one they cart off to jail.
你知道，有一次，他们想让我和他们一起去抗议拆除一个低收入住房项目。我问他你（哔）疯了吗？因为你知道吗？他们会看着你就像，嗯，他不是这里的人。但我就不一样了？我将是第一个被他们抓进监狱的人。
But in spite of residents' objections, Brandon went to Venezuela. He and a group of activists flew to Caracas. And Brandon met with an official in the Chavez government to ask for money for Common Ground. And that's when things got weird.
但尽管居民们有异议，布兰登还是去了委内瑞拉。他和一群活动人士飞往加拉加斯。布兰登会见了查韦斯政府的一名官员，为“共同基础”寻求资金。就在那时，事情变得奇怪了。
So we're in his office and I was just like in heaven, I was like, wow. I'm in this revolutionary country for the people of the United States who are oppressed. And over a period of time, the conversation turned into, would I go with him to Colombia to meet with FARC?
所以我们在他的办公室里，我简直像在天堂，我想，哇。我在这位为受压迫的美国人民服务的革命国家。在一段时间里，谈话变成了，我会和他一起去哥伦比亚见哥伦比亚革命武装力量（FARC）吗？
The FARC is a communist guerrilla group that's been at war with the Colombian government for more than 40 years, and sometimes kidnaps people. Brandon started to get panicky.
FARC 是一个共产主义游击队组织，与哥伦比亚政府交战超过40年，有时会绑架人。布兰登开始恐慌。
What if these guys are working with the FARC and want to kidnap an American with resources, or what if-- I didn't know what the heck was going on. But these guys began to pressure me, and over a number of days and over about a week, they were really laying it on me to go with them to Colombia.
如果这些人与 FARC 合作并想绑架一个有资源的美国人怎么办，或者如果——我不知道到底发生了什么。但这些人开始给我压力，在几天和大约一周的时间里，他们真的在给我施压，让我和他们一起去哥伦比亚。
What was it they were telling you? Why did they want you to?
他们告诉你什么？为什么他们想让你去？
They said they wanted to help me start a guerrilla movement in the swamps of Louisiana. And I was like, I don't think so. I don't think I'm going to do that, thank you.
他们说他们想帮我在路易斯安那州的沼泽中发动游击运动。我说我不这么认为。我想我不会那么做，谢谢。
And what--
还有什么——
Aren't you a revolutionary? Aren't you a revolutionary? Then what do you care about the danger? Come with us, come-- you should meet these people. I was like, yeah-- Not going to do it, you know?
你不是革命者吗？你不是革命者吗？那么你在乎什么危险？跟我们来，来——你应该见见这些人。我说，是啊——我不打算做，你知道吗？
Brandon, it turned out, was not a revolutionary. When push came to shove, he didn't want the violent overthrow of the US government.
布兰登，事实证明，不是一个革命者。当逼到最后时，他不想要美国政府的暴力颠覆。
When Brandon returned from Venezuela, he went back to Common Ground, but it didn't end well. The group was in chaos and having money troubles. Brandon it took over officially as director of the whole operation. And his blunt methods in contempt for consensus led to a mutiny. Around 10 coordinators at Common Ground resigned in protest. Brandon managed to stay in charge and fix some things in the organization. But within six months, he left Common Ground and never went back.
当布兰登从委内瑞拉回来后，他回到了“共同基础”，但结局并不好。该组织处于混乱中，有资金问题。布兰登正式接管了整个运营的负责人。他直率的手段和对共识的蔑视导致了一场叛变。大约10名“共同基础”的协调员辞职抗议。布兰登设法保持负责并修复了组织中的一些事情。但在六个月内，他离开了“共同基础”，再也没有回去。
Politics. It's politics, you know? We were no more morally correct than the political system of the US government. It was a big realization for me that I was on the wrong track.
政治。是政治，你知道吗？我们的道德并不比美国政府的政治体制更正确。对我来说是一个巨大的发现，我走错了路。
I didn't see Brandon for three and a half years after Katrina. And so it's strange, to say the least, to meet the former revolutionary in his hotel room in Minneapolis, where he showed me what he was planning to wear to testify against one of the activists he'd informed on for the FBI.
卡特里娜飓风后，我三年半没见布兰登。所以至少可以奇怪地在明尼阿波利斯的酒店房间里见到这位前革命者，他在那里向我展示了他打算穿什么去作证，反对他为 FBI 举报的活动人士之一。
This is my suit and underwear. I didn't bring my slacks over.
这是我的西装和内衣。我没有带我的休闲裤过来。
The FBI did not recruit Brandon. He wasn't a criminal they'd convinced to snitch in exchange for a lower sentence. He went to them, but not right away.
FBI 没有招募布兰登。他不是一个被他们说服通过出卖别人以换取更轻刑罚的罪犯。是他走向他们，但不是马上。
Coming up. How a revolutionary becomes a spy. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。革命者如何成为间谍。一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际台播出，当我们的节目继续。
This is This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Turncoats. And we return to Michael May's story about the political activist, Brandon Darby.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，每周我们在节目中选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目是“变节者”。我们回到迈克尔·梅关于政治活动家布兰登·达比的故事。
When Brandon left Common Ground and went back to Austin in the beginning of 2007, he turned toward something quite exotic to him. Ordinary life. He bought a house. His daughter was born. He tended his garden.
当布兰登在2007年初离开“共同基础”回到奥斯汀时，他转向了一些对他来说相当异国情调的东西。平凡的生活。他买了一栋房子。他的女儿出生了。他打理自己的花园。
I just tried to fit back into normalcy. Not being in New Orleans. Not being in the situation I was in in New Orleans. I think at the time, I was having a very difficult time making sense of my views, I guess.
我只是试着融入正常。不在新奥尔良。不在我在新奥尔良的那种情况下。我想当时，我很难理清我的观点，我想。
Brandon also missed the intensity of Common Ground, and the moral certainty. He had idea for an organization called Critical Response, where he would lead medics into war zones to help civilians caught in the crossfire. They'd go to Lebanon, or maybe Darfur. But instead, one of the acquaintances he made while planning Critical Response, an older man who ran a Palestinian charity, came to him with a very different plan.
布兰登也很怀念“共同基础”的强度和道德确定性。他有一个关于一个叫“关键响应”（Critical Response）的组织的构想，他将领导医疗队进入战区帮助陷入交火的平民。他们会去黎巴嫩，或者可能是达尔富尔。但相反，他在策划“关键响应”时认识的一位熟人，一位经营巴勒斯坦慈善机构的老年人，带着一个非常不同的计划来找他。
An idea to put explosives on motorcycles so that they could go through the barricades that were meant for vehicles.
一个把爆炸物放在摩托车上的想法，这样它们就可以通过原本为车辆准备的路障。
Where?
在哪里？
In Israel. And I didn't agree with it. And that person went further to ask me to help them funnel money to Hezbollah and Hamas. And I was like, no, I'm not doing this, man.
在以色列。我不同意。那个人更进一步要求我帮助他们把钱转给真主党和哈马斯。我说，不，我不做这个，伙计。
Brandon was going to let it go. But the man started asking other people to do it. People Brandon knew. So he went to the one cop he trusted. Major Bryson of the New Orleans Police Department. His onetime adversary, now ally. It was Bryson who suggested that Brandon tell the FBI.
布兰登本来想放过它。但那个人开始要求其他人去做。布兰登认识的人。所以他找到了他信任的唯一一个警察。新奥尔良警察局的布赖森少校。他曾经的对手，现在是盟友。正是布赖森建议布兰登告诉 FBI。
So how do you do that? You just walk into the FBI office?
那么你怎么做呢？你只是走进 FBI 办公室？
No, you don't-- you could just walk in if you wanted to, I suppose. They'd probably talk with you. But a meeting was set up. He gave me a phone number. I called the number. And then that man brought another agent with him. And we met and had a cup of coffee and talked. And I left, and I drove back to Austin. And It was just a strange experience. And I was really bothered by the fact that I had met with the FBI. I felt like I had done something that I would never be able to tell anybody about.
不，你不会——我想如果你想的话，你可以直接进去。他们可能会和你谈谈。但会议安排好了。他给了我一个电话号码。我拨打了那个号码。然后那个人带着另一个特工来了。我们见面喝了杯咖啡，聊了聊。我离开了，开车回到奥斯汀。那是一种奇怪的经历。我对自己曾与 FBI 会面感到非常困扰。我觉得我做了一件我永远无法告诉任何人的事情。
And then ultimately, it began bother me. I was like, well, wait a minute. I just did something that probably prevented people from getting blown up. Who are the people I associate with that if I said, hey, I tried to stop violence, they would be upset with me?
最终，它开始困扰我。我想，嗯，等一下。我刚刚做了一件可能阻止人们被炸飞的事情。如果我说，嘿，我试图阻止暴力，跟我交往的人中谁会对我感到心烦？
And the more Brandon thought about it, the more he remembered how many times he'd come close to violent political action himself. Over the years, he'd been asked by friends to get together and rob an armored car for the revolution. He'd been invited to train to do eco-terrorism. He'd had long, serious talks about committing arson to fight gentrification. He never did any of that. But now, maybe because he'd gotten older and less angry, or because of his experiences at Common Ground and in Venezuela, he decided he needed to take a stand against it.
布兰登想得越多，他就越记得自己曾多少次接近暴力政治行动。多年来，朋友们曾要求他聚在一起抢劫一辆装甲车进行革命。他曾被邀请去受训进行生态恐怖主义。他曾进行过关于采取纵火手段对抗士绅化的长期而严肃的讨论。他从未做过任何那种事。但现在，也许是因为他变老了，愤怒减少了，或者因为他在“共同基础”和委内瑞拉的经历，他决定需要采取立场反对它。
He called the FBI back and volunteered to become an informant. And in my interviews with him, I asked him over and over-- Why go that far? I could see why he'd gone to the FBI in the first place, but to become an informant? To go undercover? Not many people would choose that option. Especially people who just bought a house and had a kid. I ran one theory by him and he didn't react well.
他给 FBI 回了电话，自愿成为线人。在对他的采访中，我一遍又一遍地问他——为什么走那么远？我能看出他为什么首先去 FBI，但成为线人？去做卧底？没有多少人会选择那个选项。特别是刚买房有了孩子的人。我对他提出了一个理论，但他反应不好。
My desire is to be a hero. Like that's a really, I feel a kind of a negative way to portray that. I don't think that's a fair analysis, you know?
我的愿望是成为英雄。这真是一个，我觉得描述它的方式非常消极。我不认为那是一个公平的分析，你知道吗？
Why is that--
为什么那是——
I don't think I want to be a hero anymore than someone who's a firefighter. Are they firefighters because they want to be a hero?
我不认为我比消防员更想成为英雄。他们是消防员是因为他们想成为英雄吗？
Yes.
是的。
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
How would you call it, then? I mean you put it like--
那你怎么称呼它呢？我的意思是如果你把它说成——
I think some people feel a natural desire to stick up for others.
我认为有些人感觉到一种自然的愿望去支持别人。
Why is this up to you?
为什么这取决于你？
'Cause it's in my lap. It's in my lap, you know? That's the deal. Is some people--
因为这在我的怀里。这在我的怀里，你知道吗？就是这样。有些人——
But Katrina wasn't in your lap.
但卡特里娜飓风不在你的怀里。
Well it kinda was in my lap though, that's the thing. Because-- it was in my lap because I had access to buy a boat. And I knew that I had just the right mentality that I was going to go and get my friend. And I knew that nobody was going to tell me I wasn't. And so I did it. That's what I did. And that's kind of been how I've always done things. That's what my brain naturally does, you know? Some people are really good with numbers and they're accountants. My brain thinks of ways to fix things I think are wrong.
嗯，这有点在我的怀里，这就是事情。因为——它在我的怀里，因为我有机会买一艘船。我知道我拥有正确的心理，我会去接我的朋友。我知道没有人能告诉我我不能。所以我做了。这就是我做的。那一直是我做事的方式。这就是我的大脑自然做的事情，你知道吗？有些人真的很擅长数字，他们是会计师。我的大脑想出修复我认为错误的事情的方法。
It was during this conversation, roughly our 17th, that I finally understood. Brandon kept using this analogy. He'd say, if you walked by an alley and saw someone getting beat up, wouldn't you try and stop it? And I thought, well yeah. But how often does that happen? Brandon is always walking by that alley.
正是在这次谈话中，大概是第17次，我终于明白了。布兰登不停地使用这个类比。他说，如果你走过一条小巷，看到有人被打，难道你不会尝试阻止它吗？我想，嗯，是啊。但这多久发生一次？布兰登总是走过那条小巷。
There some words I get sensitive about, like hero complex. But I kind of think all of us as activists have some degree of that. I definitely know I do, you know? But I think more than that the thing that doesn't feel good is when you could have saved someone and you don't. That sucks. When you can fix something and you don't. When you can't hold people accountable, and you don't.
有些词让我很敏感，比如英雄情结。但我认为我们所有作为活动家的人在某种程度上都有那种情结。我绝对知道我有，你知道吗？但我认为比那更重要的是，当你本可以拯救某人而你没有时，这种感觉并不好。这太糟了。当你能修复某事而你没有时。当你不能让人们负责时，而你没有。
So Brandon's work as an undercover informant for the FBI began. Brandon met David McKay and Brad Crowder, the two guys who were convicted of making molotov cocktails, at a meeting in Austin at the Monkey Wrench Bookstore in February of 2008.
所以布兰登作为 FBI 卧底线人的工作开始了。布兰登在2008年2月奥斯汀的 Monkey Wrench 书店的一次会议上认识了大卫·麦凯和布拉德·克劳德，这两个因制造燃烧瓶而被定罪的家伙。
A group called the RNC Welcoming Committee was recruiting protesters for the Republican National Convention in Saint Paul. The goal was to shut down the event with swarms of activists, including some using black bloc anarchist tactics. Protesters you've probably seen with black bandanas covering their faces, making human chains, pushing dumpsters into the street, breaking glass.
一个名为“共和党全国代表大会欢迎委员会”的组织正在为圣保罗的共和党全国代表大会招募抗议者。目标是用蜂拥而至的活动人士关闭活动，包括一些使用黑色集团（Black Bloc）无政府主义策略的人。抗议者你可能见过戴着黑色头巾遮住脸，组成人链，把垃圾桶推到街上，打破玻璃。
The FBI sent Brandon to the RNC Welcoming Committee meeting to check it out. Brandon thought spying on them was a waste of time, but he says when he got there the group used a phrase that alarmed him. They talked about protests involving "a diversity of tactics."
FBI 派布兰登去参加“欢迎委员会”的会议看看。布兰登认为监视他们是在浪费时间，但他说当他到达那里时，该组织使用了一个让他警觉的短语。他们谈到了涉及“多样化策略”的抗议。
It's a common term used in radical leftist circles in relation to arson.
这是激进左翼圈子中关于纵火的常用术语。
And Brandon says from that moment, it seemed possible to him that something violent might happen at the convention. Not likely, but possible.
布兰登说从那一刻起，对他来说，在大会上发生暴力事件是有可能的。不太可能，但有可能。
I think ultimately, there's a lot of bark and no bite with a lot of people. I think you have a lot of people who are very reasonable and rational, as much as I might not agree with the way they do think sometimes, pretty reasonable people. But the thing is, there are always someone who will do it, when the space is created for him to do so and the support network is set up for him to do so. I felt like there would probably be some who would do something crazy even though the majority wouldn't.
我认为最终，很多人只是雷声大雨点小。我认为你有很多非常理性的人，尽管我可能有时不同意他们的思维方式，但相当理智的人。但问题是，总会有人做，当为他创造了这样做空间并且建立了这样做支持网络时。我觉得可能会有人做点疯狂的事，尽管大多数人不会。
For the next six months, Brandon spied on guys who were essentially younger versions of himself. Two Texas activists in their early 20s who didn't have college degrees and turned to leftist politics to help them make sense of the world. Brandon identified with them, especially Brad.
在接下来的六个月里，布兰登监视了那些基本上是他自己年轻版本的家伙。两个二十出头、没有大学学位的德克萨斯活动人士，转向左翼政治以帮助他们理解世界。布兰登认同他们，尤其是布拉德。
I related to him a lot. And I related to David McKay somewhat, too. I thought he was probably a pretty decent guy who was getting caught up in some stuff that I would have hoped he wouldn't have got caught up in. My initial reaction to he and to Brad was like I should try to find a way to just get these guys and tell them the people they're associating with it are being idiots. But again that's not the role I was playing.
我非常认同他。我也在某种程度上认同大卫·麦凯。我觉得他可能是一个相当正派的人，卷入了一些我本希望他不会卷入的事情。我对他们最初的反应是我应该尝试找到一种方法抓住这些家伙，告诉他们他们交往的人是白痴。但同样，这不是我扮演的角色。
The FBI told Brandon that the role he was playing was to be accepted by the group but not to be the leader. But Brandon had an odd way of trying to pull that off. He became a sort of caricature of his former hardcore activist self. In Brandon's own FBI reports entered in David McKay's trial, he talked about berating David and Brad as tofu eaters who needed to bulk up, saying he was going to the RNC to shut the [BLEEP] down. And bragging that any group I go with will be successful. Brad Crowder wouldn't agree to an interview. But David McKay remembers the meetings with Brandon.
FBI 告诉布兰登，他扮演的角色是让群体接受，而不是成为领导者。但布兰登有一种奇怪的方式来尝试实现这一点。他成了他以前硬核活动家自己的某种讽刺画。在 David McKay 审判中提交的布兰登自己的 FBI 报告中，他谈到责骂大卫和布拉德是需要增加体重的豆腐食者，说他要去全代会关闭该死的（哔）。并吹嘘说，任何我加入的组织都会成功。布拉德·克劳德拒绝接受采访。但大卫·麦凯记得与布兰登的会议。
We had a lot of discussions about how we need to be-- how he was criticizing us about our physical-- where we were physically. He gave Brad a lot of flack about that because Brad's a very skinny individual. He's not very athletic and stuff like that. And he always, like, put him in a choke hold out of nowhere one time, just to test what Brad would do. And like things like that. Like comments about how Brad specifically, and me too, were kind of like weaklings.
我们讨论了很多关于我们需要怎么做——他如何批评我们的身体——我们在生理上的处境。他给了布拉德很多压力，因为布拉德是一个非常瘦的人。他不怎么爱运动之类的。他有一次突然把他锁喉，只是为了测试布拉德会做什么。像那样的事情。关于布拉德，还有我，有点像弱者的评论。
Why did you put up with us?
你为什么忍受我们？
Well, we really didn't want to. We really didn't. And we really didn't feel very comfortable about Brandon for a long time, but it always came into play that we had never done anything like this, ever. We didn't want to just be these guys who just showed up without any, like, credentials, or any kind of credit. And like, that's everything that Brandon was. He was the activist guy from Austin. And like with him, we felt like we were legitimate.
嗯，我们真的不想。我们真的不想。而且我们很长一段时间对布兰登感到非常不舒服，但它总是归结为我们从未做过这样的事情，从来没有。我们不想仅仅成为那些没有凭据或任何形式信用就出现的人。而这正是布兰登的一切。他是奥斯汀的活动家。有了他，我们觉得我们是合法的。
Being a revolutionary instead of an activist was kind of what he made the situation feel like. That we weren't just going here to protest, but we were coming here to fight for our beliefs. Not just to voice our opinion, but to actually fight.
成为革命者而不是活动家是他让情况感觉到的东西。我们去那里不仅仅是为了抗议，而是我们要为我们的信仰而战。不仅仅是表达我们的观点，而是真正去战斗。
Brandon says that if he was busting their chops, it was because he was trying to discourage them without stepping out of character. In other words, the very things that David says egged him on are the things Brandon says were supposed to stop him.
布兰登说，如果他在打破他们的处境，那是因为他试图劝阻他们，而不脱离角色。换句话说，大卫说诱导他的那些事情正是布兰登说应该阻止他的事情。
When they talked about their willingness to go to prison, then what I did was begin to tease them about the fact that they weren't prepared to go to prison and probably weren't prepared to make those kind of decisions for themselves. Saying like, you guys have no muscle mass. You would get killed in prison.
当他们谈论他们坐牢的意愿时，我做的是开始取笑他们，关于他们没有准备好坐牢，可能没有准备好为自己做那种决定。说就像，你们没有肌肉。你在监狱里会被杀死的。
So yes, I did say things to try to discourage them from doing stuff. And I felt the pull between my role as a person working with law enforcement and my role as just an older person who had some realizations in my life and wanted to discourage people. Was a huge dilemma for me the entire time. It was something that I struggled with the entire time.
所以是的，我确实说了些话试图劝阻他们做这件事。我感受到了作为与执法部门合作的人的角色和作为一个在生活中有一些感悟并想劝阻别人的人的角色之间的拉扯。对我来说整个时间都是一个巨大的困境。这是我一直在挣扎的事情。
In August 2008, on the eve of the Republican National Convention, Brandon traveled to Minneapolis with David, Brad and a few others in a van dragging a trailer full of homemade shields and other protest equipment. Brandon tipped off the FBI. And as soon as the group parked the U-Haul, the cops raided it and took the shields and everyone else's stuff. David and Brad were angry about the shields. And they didn't want to show up at the protest empty-handed. So David McKay says they made eight molotov cocktails in about 15 minutes with supplies they bought from a Minneapolis Walmart.
2008年8月，在共和党全国代表大会前夕，布兰登和大卫、布拉德以及其他几个人开着一辆拖着拖车的货车前往明尼阿波利斯，里面装满了自制盾牌和其他抗议设备。布兰登向 FBI 举报。就在小组停下 U-Haul 时，警察突袭了它，拿走了盾牌和每个人的其他东西。大卫和布拉德对盾牌很生气。他们不想空手出现在抗议现场。所以大卫·麦凯说他们在大约15分钟内用从明尼阿波利斯沃尔玛买来的补给品制作了八个燃烧瓶。
It was just gasoline in a bottle with little bit of oil and then he duct taped the top. And that's it.
就是瓶子里的汽油，带一点油，然后他用胶带封住了顶部。就是这样。
Where did you do it?
你在哪里做的？
In the bathroom, in the tub. Yeah. No, it is incredibly easy. The fumes were really strong, so right after we went outside. And by that time it was nighttime and we kind of just sat up on the roof and-- He going to get mad at me that I'm going to tell you this but, we talked about-- before we talked to anybody and we were like, I said to him I hope this isn't one of those "when keeping it real goes wrong" scenarios. And we kind of laughed and. No, we were very light-hearted about the whole situation.
在浴室里，在浴缸里。是的。不，这非常容易。烟雾非常浓，所以我们马上就出去了。到那时已经是晚上了，我们有点坐在屋顶上——他会因为我告诉你这个而生我的气，但我们讨论了——在我们和任何人谈话之前，我们就像，我对他说我希望这不会是那种“当保持真实出错时”的场景之一。我们有点笑了。不，我们对整个情况非常轻松。
When word got out to the rest of the activists about the molotovs, they weren't so light-hearted. In fact, they were angry.
当关于燃烧瓶的消息传到其他活动人士耳中时，他们并不那么轻松。事实上，他们很生气。
When we found like, how the group felt about the situation, that impacted us a lot because we're like, well we're going to bring something to the group of people that we'll be able to use and implement. We'll be doing another good thing. We'll be helping them out.
当我们发现小组对这种情况的感受时，这对我们影响很大，因为我们就像，嗯，我们将带给人群我们可以使用和实施的东西。我们将做另一件好事。我们会帮助他们。
When we heard from them, you know, what you're doing is ridiculous, stupid, and dangerous. That made us feel like, well, we need to rethink this.
当我们从他们那里听到，你知道，你在做的事情是荒谬的、愚蠢的和危险的。这让我们觉得，嗯，我们需要重新考虑这个。
What follows is a depressing series of events, no matter whom you believe. David and Brad never used the molotov cocktails. They left them stuffed in bags in a basement while they went out to protest. But Brandon, on behalf of the FBI, asked David what he planned to do with the molotov cocktails.
随之而来的是一系列令人沮丧的事件，无论你相信谁。大卫和布拉德从未使用过燃烧瓶。他们把它们塞在地下室的袋子里，就出去抗议了。但布兰登，代表 FBI，问大卫他打算怎么处理燃烧瓶。
David now says he didn't want to lose face with Brandon, so he made up a plan. He suggested that he and Brandon use the molotovs that night on a parking lot filled with cop cars next to a checkpoint. If David wasn't serious about doing it, as he testified, he made a terrible mistake by telling an FBI informer that's what he was planning.
大卫现在说他不想在布兰登面前丢脸，所以他编了一个计划。他建议他和布兰登那天晚上在检查站旁边的一个装满警车的停车场使用燃烧瓶。如果大卫不是认真想做这件事，正如他作证的那样，他通过告诉 FBI 线人他打算怎么做犯了一个可怕的错误。
I didn't want him to think that I was scared. Scared of what was going to happen. Or afraid of him.
我不想让他认为我害怕了。害怕会发生什么。或者害怕他。
Brandon, for his part, says he did everything he could to stop David. But again, the way he did it seems as much like goading as discouragement.
布兰登，就他而言，说他尽了一切努力去阻止大卫。但同样，他这样做的方式看起来既像鼓励又像劝阻。
I told him a lot of times, a number of times that I didn't think it was a good idea. If he wanted to back out, I wouldn't tell anybody. Nobody would know. I did say I'm a revolutionary and if you want to do this, I'll do it with you. But as a revolutionary, I think people should probably wait 'til they're 30 before they make decisions that could put them in prison for two decades. That's what I said to him. I said it over and over again. That he's not old enough to make that decision. And I'm glad I didn't make decisions like that in my 20s I think people should wait 'til their 30. He got very adamant and angry that he was going to do it whether it helped him or not, and I was like fine. And at a point, I let it go.
我告诉过他很多次，多次，我不认为这是个好主意。如果他想退出，我不会告诉任何人。没有人会知道。我确实说过我是革命者，如果你想做这个，我会和你一起做。但作为革命者，我认为人们可能应该等到30岁再做可能让他们坐牢20年的决定。这就是我对他说的话。我一遍又一遍地对他说了。他不够大，无法做那个决定。我很高兴我在20多岁时没有做那样的决定，我认为人们应该等到30岁。他变得非常坚决和愤怒，说不管有没有帮助他都要做，我就像好吧。在某一点上，我放手了。
David and Brandon agreed to meet at 2:00 AM. But when the time rolled around, David blew it off. And then he stopped responding to Brandon's calls. At 4:30 AM, David was awoken by a police officer pointing a rifle at him. He was asleep next to a girl he'd met in Saint Paul. It was around an hour before he was going to the airport to fly back to Austin.
大卫和布兰登约定凌晨2点见面。但时间到了，大卫放了鸽子。然后他停止回复布兰登的电话。凌晨4:30，大卫被一名警察用步枪指着唤醒。他睡在一个他在圣保罗认识的女孩旁边。离他去机场飞回奥斯汀还有一个小时左右。
Since then, both Brad and David have pled guilty to the possession of unregistered firearms, which is what the law calls molotov cocktails.
从那时起，布拉德和大卫都对拥有未注册枪支表示认罪，这就是法律称燃烧瓶的东西。
Here's a good one. You're a whore.
这里有一个好的。你是个妓女。
A few months later, Brandon is sitting at his desk reading emails.
几个月后，布兰登坐在桌前阅读电子邮件。
Brandon, was curious how much money the FBI compensated you for being a sewer rat. Why didn't you advise and guide your friends towards nonviolence? Why not? Because you must be a brainless, heartless FBI whore. Congratulations on your brilliant career of whoring your soul. I'm kind of envious. Does it pay well to be a whore?
布兰登，好奇 FBI 为你做一个下水道老鼠补偿了你多少钱。为什么你不建议和引导你的朋友走向非暴力？为什么不？因为你一定是一个没脑子、没心的 FBI 妓女。祝贺你辉煌的出卖灵魂的职业生涯。我有点嫉妒。做妓女赚钱吗？
It didn't pay well actually, Brandon got a total of $12,750 from the FBI, plus $3,028 in expenses.
实际上并不赚钱，布兰登从 FBI 总共得到了12,750美元，加上3,028美元的费用。
As a result of his informing, he's been skewered in the alternative press and shunned by many friends. He's gotten death threats.
由于他的举报，他在另类媒体上被刺穿，并被许多朋友回避。他收到了死亡威胁。
You feel 100% certain that law enforcement was right way to go with this?
你百分之百确定执法部门是这样做的正确方法吗？
No, I don't feel 100% certain of anything. It depends on you ask me. You know? It depends when you ask. Sometimes I feel bad enough for them that I don't go to sleep. They made their choices. I made my choices, and we both have things to live with.
不，我什么都不确定。这取决于你问我。你知道吗？这取决于你什么时候问。有时我觉得他们很可怜，以至于我睡不着觉。他们做了他们的选择。我做了我的选择，我们都有必须共存的事情。
Here's what Brandon has to live with, as I see it. In one of the first emails he wrote to the FBI after meeting Brad and David. He worried that they might end up as quote "some strange form of collateral damage."
这就是我认为布兰登必须共存的事情。在他遇到布拉德和大卫后写给 FBI 的第一封电子邮件中。他担心他们可能会最终成为某种奇怪形式的“附带损害”。
I don't think this means Brandon somehow encouraged Brad and David to make the molotov cocktails, as David's lawyer argued, and as activists all over the country now believe. But I do think that if Brad and David had met Brandon as he actually was, not in character, not playing a role for the FBI, but as an older activist and a natural leader who was profoundly regretful over the extremism of his past views. He would have stopped them from making molotov cocktails. And Brad and David wouldn't be facing years in prison.
我不认为这意味着布兰登以某种方式鼓励布拉德和大卫制作燃烧瓶，正如大卫的律师辩称的那样，正如现在全国各地的活动人士所相信的那样。但我确实认为，如果布拉德和大卫遇到了真实的布兰登，不是扮演角色，不是为 FBI 扮演角色的布兰登，而是作为一名更年长的活动家和天生领导者，他对自己过去观点的极端主义深感后悔。他会阻止他们制作燃烧瓶。而布拉德和大卫就不会面临多年的监禁。
Michael May in Austin Texas. Brad Crowder was sentenced to two years in prison for making and possessing molotov cocktails at the Republican National Convention. David McKay was just sentenced this week. Four years.
迈克尔·梅在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。布拉德·克劳德因在共和党全国代表大会上制造和持有燃烧瓶被判入狱两年。大卫·麦凯本周刚被判刑。四年。
[MUSIC  - "I SPY (FOR THE FBI) BY JAMO THOMAS]
[音乐 - “I SPY (FOR THE FBI) BY JAMO THOMAS]
Act Three. "If the Shoe Fits."
第三幕，“如果鞋子合脚”。
Well, we end our program today with this story of somebody trying not to be a turn coat. From Etgar Keret, who lives in Israel. I'm going to a mention that so you don't wonder, why is this story happening in Israel? It's read for us by actor Matt Malloy.
好吧，今天我们以这个关于某人试图不成为变节者的故事结束我们的节目。来自住在以色列的埃特加·克雷特（Etgar Keret）。我要提一下，这样你就不会疑惑，为什么这个故事发生在以色列？它由演员马特·马洛伊（Matt Malloy）为我们朗读。
On Holocaust Commemoration Day, our teacher Sarah took us on the number 57 bus to  the Vohlin Memorial Museum and I felt really important. All the kids in my class had families that came from Iraq except me and my cousin, and one other kid, Druckman. And I was the only one whose grandfather died in the Holocaust.
在犹太人大屠杀纪念日，我们的老师莎拉带我们坐57路公交车去沃林纪念博物馆（Vohlin Memorial Museum），我觉得自己很重要。班上所有的孩子家庭都来自伊拉克，除了我和我的表弟，还有另一个孩子，德鲁克曼（Druckman）。我是唯一一个祖父死在大屠杀中的人。
The Vohlin Memorial Museum is a really fancy building, all covered in expensive-looking black marble. It had a lot of sad pictures in black and white, and lists of people and countries and victims. We paired up and walk along the wall from one picture to the next. And the teacher said not to touch, but I did.
沃林纪念博物馆是一座非常漂亮的建筑，到处覆盖着看起来昂贵的黑色大理石。它有很多黑白悲伤的照片，以及人名、国家和受害者的名单。我们结成对子沿着墙从一张照片走到下一张。老师说不要触摸，但我碰了。
I touched one of them. A cardboard photograph of a pale and skinny man who was crying and holding a sandwich. The tears running down his cheeks were like the stripes on an asphalt street. And Orit Salem, the girl I was paired up with, said she'd tell the teacher on me. I said as far as I was concerned, she could tell everyone, even the principal. I didn't care. That was my grandfather. And I could touch whatever I wanted.
我碰了其中一个。一张纸板照片，是一个正在哭泣并拿着三明治的苍白瘦削的男人。顺着脸颊流下的泪水就像沥青街道上的条纹。和我配对的女孩奥里特·塞勒姆（Orit Salem）说她要告诉老师。我说只要我关心，她可以告诉所有人，甚至校长。我不在乎。那是我的祖父。我可以触摸我想触摸的任何东西。
After the pictures, they took us into a big hall and showed us a movie about little kids being loaded onto a truck. They all choked on gas in the end. After that this skinny old guy came up on stage and told us how the Nazis were scum and murderers. And how I got back at them, and even strangled a soldier to death with his bare hands.
照片之后，他们把我们带进一个大厅，放了一部关于小孩子被装上卡车的电影。最后他们都被毒气窒息了。在那之后，那个瘦削的老人上台告诉我们纳粹是人渣和杀人犯。以及他是如何报复他们的，甚至用双手活活勒死了一名士兵。
Jerabi, who was sitting next to me, said the old man was lying. And from the looks of him, there wasn't a soldier in the world he could beat up. But I looked into the old man's eyes and I believed him. There were so much anger in them that all the attacks of all the hot shot punks in the world seem like small change by comparison. In the end, after he was finished telling us about what he'd done in the Holocaust, the old man said that everything we'd heard was important. Not just for the past, but for what was happening now, too. Because the Germans were still living, and they still had a country.
坐在我旁边的杰拉比（Jerabi）说老人在撒谎。从他的样子看，这世界上没有他能打败的士兵。但我看着老人的眼睛，我相信他。里面有太多的愤怒，以至于世界上所有热血朋克的所有攻击相比之下似乎都只是小意思。最后，在他讲完他在大屠杀中所做的事情后，老人说我们听到的一切都很重要。不仅为了过去，也为了现在正在发生的事情。因为德国人还活着，他们还有一个国家。
The old man said he'd never forgive them and he hoped we wouldn't either. And that we should never, ever go visit their country, God forbid. Because when he and his parents had arrived in Germany 50 years ago, everything looked really nice. And it ended in hell.
老人说他永远不会原谅他们，希望我们也不会。我们应该永远、永远不要去访问他们的国家，上帝保佑。因为当他和他的父母50年前到达德国时，一切看起来都很棒。结局却是地狱。
People have short memories sometimes, he says. Especially for bad things. They prefer to forget, but don't you forget. Every time you see a German, remember what I told you. And every time you see anything that was made in Germany, even if it's a TV, always remember that the picture tube and the other parts underneath the pretty wrapping were made out of the bones, and skin, and flesh of dead Jews.
人们有时记性很短，他说。特别是对于坏事。他们更喜欢忘记，但你们别忘了。每次看到德国人，记住我告诉你们的话。每次看到德国制造的任何东西，即使是一台电视，永远记住显像管和其他零件在漂亮的包装下都是由死犹太人的骨头、皮肤和肉制成的。
On our way out, Jerabi said again and if that old man had strangled so much as a cucumber, he'd eat his t-shirt. And I thought it was lucky our fridge was made in Israel, 'cause who needs trouble?
在我们出去的路上，杰拉比再次说，如果那个老人勒死过哪怕一根黄瓜，他就把自己的 T 恤吃掉。我觉得幸运的是我们的冰箱是以色列制造的，因为谁需要麻烦呢？
Two weeks later, my parents came back from abroad and brought me a pair of sneakers. My older brother told my mother that's what I wanted. And she bought the best ones. Mom smiled when she handed them to me. She was sure I didn't know what was in the bag. But I could tell right away by the Adidas logo. I took the shoe box out of the bag and said thank you.
两周后，我的父母从国外回来，给我带了一双运动鞋。我哥哥告诉我母亲那就是我想要的。她买了最好的。妈妈递给我时微笑着。她确信我不知道袋子里是什么。但我一眼就通过 Adidas 的标志看出来了。我把鞋盒从袋子里拿出来说谢谢。
The box was rectangular. Like a coffin. And inside it lay two white shoes with three blue stripes on them. And on the side it said Adidas Rom. I didn't have to open the box to know that. Let's try them on, Mom said, pulling the paper out. See if they fit.
盒子是长方形的。像棺材一样。里面放着两双白色鞋子，上面有三条蓝色条纹。旁边写着 Adidas Rom。我不必打开盒子就知道那个。妈妈拉出纸，让我们试穿一下，妈妈说。看看合不合脚。
She was smiling the whole time. She didn't realize what was happening. They're from Germany, you know?, I told her and squeezed her hand hard. Of course I know, Mom smiled, Adidas is the best make the world. Grandpa was from Germany, too, I tried hinting. Grandpa was from Poland, Mom corrected me. She grew sad for a moment. But it passed right away, and she put one of the shoes on my foot and started lacing it up.
她一直微笑着。她没意识到发生了什么。你知道它们是德国制造的吗？我告诉她并紧紧握住她的手。我当然知道，妈妈微笑着，Adidas 是世界上最好的品牌。祖父也是德国人，我试图暗示。祖父是波兰人，妈妈纠正我。她难过了一会儿。但这马上过去了，她把一只鞋穿在我的脚上，开始系鞋带。
I didn't say anything. I knew by then it was no use. Mom was clueless. She never been to the Vohlin Memorial Museum. Nobody had ever explained it to her. And for her, shoes were just shoes. And Germany was really Poland. So I let her put them on my feet and I didn't say anything. There was no point in telling her. It would just make her sadder. After I said thank you one more time and gave her a kiss on the cheek, I said I was going out to play.
我什么也没说。那时我就知道没用了。妈妈什么都不知道。她从来没去过沃林纪念博物馆。从来没人给她解释过。对她来说，鞋子只是鞋子。德国实际上是波兰。所以我让她把它们穿在我的脚上，我什么也没说。告诉她没有意义。那只会让她更难过。我又说了一次谢谢，在她脸上亲了一下后，我说我要出去玩。
Watch it, eh? Dad kidded from his armchair in the living room. Don't you go wearing down the soles in a single afternoon. I took another look at the pale leather shoes on my feet. And thought back about all the things the old man who strangled the soldier said we should remember. I touched the Adidas stripes again, and remembered my Grandpa in the cardboard photograph.
小心点，嗯？爸爸从客厅的扶手椅里开玩笑说。别在一个下午就把鞋底磨坏了。我看着脚上那双浅色皮鞋。想起那个勒死士兵的老人说我们应该记住的所有事情。我又摸了摸 Adidas 的条纹，想起了纸板照片里的祖父。
Are the shoes comfortable? Mom asked. Of course they're comfortable, my brother answered instead of me. Those shoes aren't just some cheap local brand. They're the very same shoe that Pele used to wear. I tiptoed slowly towards the door, trying to put as little weight on them as possible. I kept walking that way towards Ben Gurion Park.
鞋子舒服吗？妈妈问。当然舒服，我哥哥代替我回答。那些鞋子不仅仅是什么便宜的本地品牌。它们是贝利（Pele）过去穿的同一双鞋。我慢慢地朝门口踮着脚尖走去，尽量减少对它们的压力。我就那样一直向本·古里安公园（Ben Gurion Park）走去。
Outside, the kids from Borouchoff Elementary were forming three soccer teams-- Holland, Argentina, and Brazil. The Holland group was one player short, so they agreed to let me join even though they usually never took anyone who didn't go to Borouchoff. When the game started, I still remembered to be careful not to kick with a tip, so I wouldn't hurt Grandpa. But as it continued, I forgot. Just like the old man at the Vohlin Memorial Museum said people do. And I even scored the tiebreaker with a volley kick.
在外面，来自 Borouchoff 小学的小孩们正在组成三支足球队——荷兰、阿根廷和巴西。荷兰队少一个球员，所以他们同意让我加入，尽管他们从不接受不去 Borouchoff 的人。当比赛开始时，我仍然记得要小心不要用脚尖踢，这样我就不会伤害祖父。但随着比赛继续，我忘记了。就像沃林纪念博物馆的老人说的人们会那样。我甚至用凌空抽射打进了决胜球。
After the game was over, I remembered and looked down at them. They were so comfortable all of a sudden. And springier, too. Much more than they'd seemed when they were still in the box. What a volley that was, eh? I'm reminded Grandpa on our way home. The goalie didn't even know what hit him. Grandpa didn't say anything. But from the bounce in my step, I could tell he was happy, too.
比赛结束后，我记了起来，低头看了看它们。它们突然变得非常舒服。也更有弹性。比它们还在盒子里的时候看起来要好得多。多么精彩的凌空抽射，嗯？我在回家的路上提醒祖父。守门员甚至不知道是什么击中了他。祖父什么也没说。但从我的步伐中，我可以看出他也很快乐。
Matt Malloy, reading the story "Shoes" from Etgar Keret's collection of short fiction that's titled, The Bus Driver Who Wanted to be God, and Other Stories.
马特·马洛伊阅读埃特加·克雷特短篇小说集《想当上帝的公交车司机及其他故事》中的故事《鞋子》。
Our program is produced today by Sarah Keonig and me. With Alex Blumberg. Jane Geltes, publicist. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Andy Dixon. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help by Jessica Hopper.
我们今天的节目由莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Keonig）和我制作。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）。珍·格尔特斯（Jane Geltes），公关。以及南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。安迪·迪克森（Andy Dixon）提供制作帮助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）提供音乐帮助。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International WBEZ Management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who was against WBEZ's proposed relocation for him and his family.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际（Public Radio International）分发。我们节目的 WBEZ 管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Mr. Torey Malatia）先生负责，他反对 WBEZ 为他和他的家人提议的搬迁。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
I don't, I don't, I don't want the Ayatollah buying me any houses. That's OK. I'd rather be homeless.
我不，我不，我不想要阿亚图拉给我买任何房子。没关系。我宁愿无家可归。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories from This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到这里，带来更多来自《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC]
[音乐]